the hardest thing about diplomacy is
keeping a straight face well u.s defense
secretary lloyd austin is great at it of
course wearing a mask helps austin's
been over in south korea and among other
things he's still a bit worried about
those hypersonic missiles that china
appears to have up its sleeve
so it's china's missiles that quote
increased tensions in the region i mean
missiles do but more specifically these
ones cause tensions in america where
they could theoretically reach we have
concerns about the military capabilities
that
the prc continues to pursue
and the pursuit of those capabilities
increases increases tensions in the
region but for a laugh let's consider
whether anything else might be causing
tensions in the region whether it takes
two to do the tension tango
not sure about that line for some time
the us has been pushing south korea to
join the noble mission
but seoul has kind of always avoided
really getting involved because it knows
which side its bread is buttered the
reality is that south korea
and china
have a tremendous economic relationship
but now even south korea has been sucked
into the whole shtick we shared our
assessments of the changing and complex
regional security environment
and we emphasize our shared commitment
to the rules-based order in the
indo-pacific they never say the word
china for the first time according to
reuters the two sides america and south
korea agreed to a statement which
stressed the importance of preserving
peace and stability in the taiwan strait
fyi that's um diplomatic talk for
meanwhile not far away relatively
speaking former japanese prime minister
shinzo abe entered the fray ms abe had
said japan and the us would not stand
idly by if china attacked taiwan notice
he said japan and the u.s well that
fighting talk caused beijing to summon
the japanese ambassador and shout at him
also the department of defense has just
finished its so-called global posture
review and
the conclusion of the global posture
review comes at a key inflection point
as the department increases our focus on
china yeah so among the few things that
were actually made public from this
review
to quote cnn the pentagon will focus on
building up bases in guam and australia
to better prepare the us military to
this essentially in the tiny pacific
paradise of guam operation iron island
is underway oh yeah and a pentagon is
testing israel's iron dome missile
defense system on guam it will be used
to defend the island as china stockpiles
missiles so the u.s maneuvers fence
sitting south korea to join the pylon
against beijing japan de facto threatens
china with its alliance with washington
and by the way basically japan and south
korea hate each other because of history
and the pentagon announces it's planning
to build up its military bases in key
parts of the pacific all in a week i
haven't even mentioned the u.s
politicians and generals that visited
taiwan so yeah stop causing all those
tensions chyna jeez